[Musique]
le prince Harry n'en finit pas de faire
trembler Buckingham Palace on est dans
Amour gloire et beauté à mort amor c'est
un feuilleton incroyable alors qu'il
multiplie les interviews télé vient de
sortir une série documentaire avec
Mégane sur Netflix il s'apprête cette
fois à publier son autobiographie dans
quelques jours un livre choc traduit en
16 langues différentes où il compte
faire d'étonnantes déclaration et pour
lequel le prince aurait empoché un joli
montant Harry il a reçu 20 millions de
dollars de la part de l'éditeur mais
tandis que son ouvrage le suppléant ne
sort que dans 5 jours des éléments
accablants ont déjà fuité dans la presse
Harry et Williams se sont battus des
révélations incroyables qui choquent
aujourd'hui les Britanniques et le monde
entier Harry et Williams se serait donc
battus alors que s'est-il passé entre
les deux frères Bertrand Deckers nous
dit tout ce soir dans TPMP
comme moi je comprends jamais rien
est-ce qu'on peut mettre une photo de
Harry mettre Harry et mettre William
c'est moi et ce matin je savais plus qui
était qui s'embrouille avec William
c'est lui non
celui qui est le fils du celui-là donc
William a tapé Harry c'est ça donc le
nez à tapé le benjamin voilà le futur
roi
91 pour William contre un mètre 86 pour
Harry d'accord par contre ça va toi oui
ça va
habiller au costume ou quoi oui oui au
déguisement
comment tu vas mon chéri
non mais c'est vrai que l'année 2022
était un peu compliqué pour toi avec la
perte de des abeilles attentifs non mais
c'est vrai tu as été quand même bah non
c'est vrai quand Elisabeth est morte
c'est comme si pour moi il y avait plus
de Danette
c'est un truc de fou croyez pas ça nous
a meurtri mais lui euh frère
il est magnifique alors c'est mon petit
protégé c'est mon petit protégé j'ai
beaucoup de projets avec lui il le sait
pas
Bertrand mon chéri merci tu vas nous
raconter déjà que tu soutiens qui toi à
votre avis
non William
donc le grand même si c'est celui qui
frappe mais je vais tenter de vous
expliquer quand même que voilà bah alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce qu'il
apparemment qu'est-ce qu'il y a une
embrouille la fameuse biographie le
suppléant sort mardi matin incroyable
ça c'est voilà super le livre que Harry
a écrit 10 millions d'exemplaires m'ont
été tirés dans 16 langues donc il existe
en chinois en chinois en hongrois en
anglais évidemment en anglais 514
pour la version française
établi ils se sont basés sur le plan qui
avait été orchestré par JK avec Harry
Potter et les Reliques de la Mort le
dernier tour qui s'était vendu lui à
plus de 40 millions de tomes
c'est-à-dire que oui c'est-à-dire que
les livres sont acheminés à bord de
camions qui sont géolocalisés de façon à
ce que le camion puisse bel et bien on
est certain que les camions va dans la
librairie une fois que les camions
arrivent dans la vie les palettes seront
lesquelles les livres ont été déposés il
y a une alarme suppresseur
la rencontre Daniel Guichard Bertrand
Deckers pour moi c'est déjà exceptionnel
reste calme mais il nous regarde Daniel
mais on va faire un duo tous les deux
mais il est pas il est fascinant il est
exceptionnel
pour que ça reste secret et malgré tout
depuis ce matin il y a des premiers
bruits qui commencent à circuler des
fuites on pense bien qu'elles sont
volontaires ces fuites là puisque c'est
le gardien qui est quand même très
proche de Harry et de gardien
le gardien voilà le rage voilà ce qui
est enquête de Ravi n'est pas du tout le
rage le rage voilà c'est le rage à titre
quotidien qui n'est pas du tout de la
haie ce tableau vide et qui nous balance
en effet que quoi une anecdote parmi
tant d'autres en janvier 2019 William
particulièrement énervé suite à une
énième dispute traverser les jardins de
Kensington au petit matin
à la porte était obligé de tout Minerve
non mais il fait bien
le ton à monter certains termes ont été
prononcé alors
difficile
allez foods
de savoir-vivre il a dit quoi je suis
pas d'accord Harry William il a dit quoi
William a dit à rire cette fille
cette fille est difficile de chaise
difficulté
voilà elle pose des problèmes elle est
un peu lire et elle est chiante toi il a
dit quoi
par contre toute attente il faut savoir
que William est le parfait élève
d'Elisabeth 2 quand vous commencez à
toucher à la monarchie bien il ne se
sent plus qu'est-ce qu'il a fait du haut
de ça
par le col ah non
il est énervé calme-toi
au milieu de la cuisine du papillon
et retomber dans la gamelle du chat
pareil depuis d'abord
en porcelaine puisque éclatait en mille
morceaux c'est vrai oui mais c'est bon
et alors il dit alors il dit suite à
cela j'ai gardé des cicatrices
mais je pense quand même que les deux
frangins ils ont du scotter quelquefois
depuis qu'ils sont petits hein bien sûr
donc c'est pas la première fois c'est
qu'on peut mettre en lumière c'est que
là voilà on sait que c'est depuis ça que
en effet et bien il y a une rupture
totale puisque suite à cette rupture là
les deux frères se sont complètement
séparés géographiquement puisqu'il va
quitter son petit pavillon de Nottingham
package pour aller rejoindre la campagne
à Windsor dans une propriété beaucoup
plus impossible
pour le coup il ne se verront presque
plus physiquement et est-ce que les deux
meufs elles s'entendent bien mais voilà
et on danse vraiment que tout cela c'est
une bagarre
et Kate Middleton
du PAF série
beaucoup d'affinités elle a beaucoup de
ressemblances
je prends des cours d'arabe alors
imagine que je suis Kate Middleton
longtemps que tu sais pour devenir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un Pula et sinon tu as quoi d'autre
les histoires elles ne cessent d'arriver
et il y en a d'autres évidemment qui
nous sont racontés par d'autres
journalistes qui ont quand même réussi
apparemment ah obtenir un exemplaire du
livre je vous le disais on pense d'accès
volontaire un moment donné un autre
titre de presse à titre anglais celui-ci
et bien Harry dévoile que il a supplié
son père le prince Charles de ne jamais
épouser Camila tant Camila était à
l'origine vous savez de la détresse
il revient il s'appelle comment
maintenant des années en Afghanistan
s'appelle comment est la reine qu'on
sort non on doit la sortir
tous les matins il revient tous les
soirs la reine cochon on y va allez
ça fait 60 ans
c'est demain prenons pas fait demain
pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait demain avec
une galette enfin qui s'explique il faut
quelques mois quand même après le décès
dans souveraineté est morte on le
rappelle lui
organiser
avec une couronne il va se changer il va
il portera lors de la famille la fameuse
ou pas 2300 g de pierre précieuses
ça va être chaud la couronne ah les
oreilles qui vont partir ça va être
indéniable je te le dis à mon avis et il
est en 2 minutes vous avez plein de
questions en train d'être retravailler
les fameuses couronnes pour la chanson
en train d'être adaptées
un casse Bluetooth
il doit s'entraîner ouais
de Saint-Étienne
torticolis mais ce serait pire que ça il
a 74 ans grâce comme on l'appelle le
coup du lapin
j'imagine le gars il a éclate quoi
je l'adore Charline est sympa ou pas
Charlie Charlie Charlie il est très
sympa je connais parfaitement le
français en humour incroyable parce que
c'est comme il est d'accord
regardez comme il est darka il est
sucréaliste Charles tu sais depuis qu'il
est tout petit c'est qu'il sera roi mais
tu sais qu'il est devenu beaucoup plus
beau maintenant qu'avant ah ouais tu es
trop ouais je te jure
il est quand même vachement au polo
c'est pas bien ce que tu as fait parce
que tu racontes la bagarre comme si
c'était William tu vois qui était le
héros de cette bagarre alors qu'en fait
il a poussé il a poussé Harry et il
s'est comporté après comme un fouet
comme un voyou le Guardian le dit il lui
a dit à toi de me taper si tu es un
homme et tout après il est parti il est
venu s'excuser il lui a dit et surtout
n'en parle pas à Mégane et tout ça donc
oui mais ça tu l'as pas dit parce que ça
t'arrange pas parce que William c'est un
hypocrite et ça toi tu aimes pas ça donc
essaye de raconter la vérité pour une
fois Bertrand Becker voilà on en parlera
enfin tout mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
oh
mon cher Gilles que j'aime à qui je
souhaite une merveilleuse année fais
gaffe une fois qu'on commençait à
écorner la couronne il ne se sentait
plus il était excédé il est excessif il
peut devenir brutal et d'ailleurs Kate
Middleton la première dit je dois
réfléchir parfois longuement pour savoir
comment je vais présenter un fait à
William non
copains
aussi le William du pape
toi tu es mon bébé
bah pour être sublime aujourd'hui
Natacha voilà alors surtout ne vous
énervez donc ce que je voulais
simplement dire c'est que pour moi
l'histoire vraiment c'est la série de
Crown et également le reportage enfin la
série Netflix sur Mégane et Harry qui
m'a vraiment fait réfléchir et qui et
qui m'a fait sortir si vous voulez de
l'histoire de la jalousie entre les deux
femmes etc que je trouvais un petit peu
réductrice et carrément même machiste et
là vraiment ce qui m'a vraiment sauté à
l'esprit c'est c'est le fait que ce
qu'est à l'esprit génial
c'est le fait que c'est le fait qu'en
fait dans le reportage enfin dans dans
cette série Mégane et Harry Harry parle
énormément de sa mère bien ça c'est la
première chose le problème de l'autre
côté c'est que William lui et drivé pour
le moment enfin excusez-moi du choix du
terme mais enfin il est complètement on
le prépare à devenir ou un jour et que
son papa qui est le nouveau roi et qui
donc le préparer également son papa lui
il n'a eu de cesse que double de fer
oublier Diana et que c'est il était
lui-même très jaloux de la popularité de
Diana à l'époque et ça ça a été relaté
de façon assez je dirais
clairement arrangé
et puis ensuite et puis ensuite le
William il est dépossédé si vous voulez
de l'affection de de que Harry peut
vraiment de façon démonstrative
expliciter etc peut
il peut en parler à tout le monde quoi
en gros et ce qui n'est pas le cas de de
William c'est pas le cas de William
William il est privé de cette parole il
est privé de la liberté et puis même et
puis en plus il a rajouté aussi c'est le
fait que Mégane pour résumer elle dit
l'autre
fois William il est vénère parce que en
fait l'otarie il fait que de voilà
sachez sur la famille
voilà avec ça voilà et l'autre qui dit
ouais ouais William voilà parce que
William genre il est triste parce que
l'autre il fait croire qu'il aimait plus
sa mère que lui et donc voilà donc
[Rires]
est-ce que je peux est-ce que je peux te
dire un truc est-ce que je peux dire un
truc qui me tient vraiment à cœur
donc cette histoire tu nous as tout dit
là-dessus je pense c'est bon oui parce
que moi je vais te dire un truc je m'en
bats tous les jours
à scandale je te fais venir juste pour
toi
je m'en bats les critiques je voyais
c'est le fait que ils sont payés des
montants astronomiques voilà là encore
c'est plus de 20 millions pas pour le
livre voilà
le monde entier en mode ayant en plus
les interviews
on va arrêter là c'est bon qu'ils ont
souffert j'ai lancé